[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Welcome,
everyone, in the series
of "Talks at Google."
Today we'll be hearing from
Bryan Franklin, a business
strategist who's helped seven
companies go from startup
to over a billion dollars.
He once coached 35
Google executives,
and specializes in conditions
of massive uncertainty,
such as the coming years.
His co-author, Michael Ellsberg,
previously wrote the book,
"The Education of
Millionaires-- Everything
You Won't Learn in
College About How
to be Successful," by Penguin.
And his writings
have been featured
in "The New York
Times," "The Washington
Post," and Forbes.com.
[APPLAUSE]
BRYAN FRANKLIN: So
it's our conjecture
that every one of you
is sitting on a massive
and massively
underutilized asset.
And in fact, that
in your future,
when you look back at
what-- economically
and otherwise-- were your
biggest leverage points,
your biggest assets,
your biggest advantages,
you're going to look back
on the class of assets
that we're going to discuss
here as the most advantageous
and the most important.
And they're probably
assets that you're
paying almost no attention to.
And you might not even
think of as investments.
So we're going to
look at those today
and see if we can de-code
why so many have struggled
to make a traditional
investing model work for them,
why we're in the global economic
situation that we're in,
and then what we
can do about it now.
MICHAEL ELLSBERG:
So before we go
into the kind of investing
we're talking about,
we're going to just
do a little overview
of the traditional investment
advice that's generally given,
that many of you have probably
heard in different forms.
We call this the financial
advice commonly delivered,
or FACD, for short.
And it's a pretty simple model.
It starts with
earn-- work a job,
earn however much you earn.
Then the next step in the model
is save as much as possible.
The typical advice that you see
in a lot of personal finance
books is scrimp and save,
don't drink premium coffee,
have the cheapest
coffee you can.
You know, watch videos instead
of taking your sweetie out
to a movie.
Scrimp and save every
little penny you can.
And then the next step
is take those savings
and invest them in the market,
mutual funds, 401Ks, index
funds, that kind of thing.
And in the plan they say,
watch that money grow.
Typically the figure
that they'll cite
is that the markets,
broadly, have
risen about 7% per
year, annualized
over the last decades and
decades, 80, 100 years.
And so that's what they'll
tell you to expect.
And then if you work all
the numbers right and plan
everything right, you
can then-- on the growth
of what you saved to
invest-- you can, last step,
retire at 65, or when
you want to retire.
And that's the pretty
picture they paint.
In our book, we talk
about how that plan is
broken at basically every step.
And rather than go
into detail about all
the ways we think it's broken,
the one thing I'll highlight
right now, that I think
is problematic from that,
is that really
the investing part
is totally devoid
of anything that
has to do with your
own human capital.
So you'll never hear an
investment adviser at Schwab--
or wherever you go for your
investment advice-- talk
about your human capital,
the skills and earning power
you have, as part of
your investment plan.
They don't even
really talk about it.
They'll just say,
well, your investing
is this stuff you
do with our funds
that we're going to put you in.
And that's what investing is.
And so it basically separates
investing from anything
that you have skill or
control or domain over.
Which we think is a
pretty big problem.
And we're going to
talk about that more.
BRYAN FRANKLIN: I think
one of the reasons
why this plan-- I mean, the
plan seems like it would work.
Right?
You earn, you save, you try
and save as much as possible.
And then you keep
reinvesting the growth
from compound interest
and over time.
Then you can stop
working and be happy.
It makes sense.
And it makes so much sense that
most people in our generation,
and most millennials, have
a vague sense of guilt when
they don't follow that plan.
Just because it's
supposed to work.
But I think the reason
why it doesn't is actually
an optimization problem.
It's optimizing for
one aspect of a system
at the expense of
the larger system.
And anytime you optimize
one aspect of any system
at the expense of the larger
system, the larger system,
of course, eventually
will collapse.
And I think that's a pretty
good characterization
for the average American's-- for
example-- financial situation.
And that's the richest
country in the world.
The section that that
plan optimizes for
is just your financial
net worth-- the amount
that you would say that you
have in savings and investments,
the value of what you
have on your balance
sheet less your liabilities.
And the problem is, we
actually don't-- as humans--
we actually don't care
about that intrinsically.
We don't care about having a lot
of static wealth intrinsically.
We want static wealth because
of all of the other things
we think it will get us-- life
experiences, access, privilege,
options, freedom, choices.
So we want access and freedom
and choices and experiences.
And we think that we need
this static wealth in order
to have that.
But those options
and experiences
live inside the same system with
the finances, with the money.
And often times, we
make choices which
limit our freedom, which
limit our access, which
limit the sense of luxury, which
limit our own enjoyment, which
limit our ability to have
the kind of experiences
that we want, in order
to make more money,
in order to save more money,
in order to invest more money.
And anytime you
sacrifice from the whole
to accentuate the part, that's
when the system which would,
of course, collapse.
So broadly speaking,
you could say,
that the purpose of any
financial plan is to be happy,
to be happy with your life.
And particularly, to be happy
with your life over a prolonged
period of time.
And that happiness
could be arrived
at through, again, freedom
to travel or the freedom not
to work, or to live
in a particular area,
or to have the
particular choices.
And what's interesting is
that the studies on happiness
reveal that sudden increases
in financial capital,
like winning the lottery,
over the medium term,
after a few months, do
absolutely nothing to increase
your sense of happiness.
In fact, there was a
scientist I saw do a talk
on the science of happiness.
And he began this
talk by saying,
with respect to being
happy, would you
prefer winning the lottery
or becoming a paraplegic?
Which of the two do you
think would make you happier?
And of course, I'd much
rather win the lottery
than become a paraplegic.
Although the studies show
that neither of those events
have impact on
long-term happiness.
What does have a impact on
long-term happiness, number
one, is getting enough sleep.
Number two is doing everyday
things with friends.
So instead of going
to the DMV alone,
going with your two
or three best friends,
doing your grocery
shopping with other people.
These kinds of
things, like that,
have a meaningful impact
on your baseline happiness
over years and years.
Being in service has an
impact on your happiness.
And of course,
learning something
has an impact on your happiness.
People who are engaged
in self development
generally are more happy,
more engaged, more alive,
more enlivened.
When I work with corporations
on creating the kind of company
and environments that
employers are going
to be really loyal
to, number one
is make sure that every employee
has a powerful development
plan that they,
themselves, are directing,
and that they see the
company as an opportunity
to fulfill on that development.
So these the attributes of
things that make us happy.
And those are exactly
the kinds of things
that we would sacrifice
in order to make money.
Well, I'm going to
pull an all-nighter
to make sure that I can
get the project done,
so that I get promoted.
I'm going to, more
and more, work alone.
I'm going to sacrifice sleep,
sacrifice time with friends.
So we start sacrificing
the stuff-- the happiness--
that the money is supposed
to get us back later.
And that creates a problem.
Because eventually, you become
unwilling to sacrifice anymore.
And when you reach
your limits of what
you're willing to
sacrifice, then you
pull back from achievement.
And then usually
we judge ourselves
for being a bad person,
because we're not
achieving as much as we should.
And so you get into that
cycle of underachievement,
self-judgment, and then
pushing and sacrifice, and then
underachievement, and then
pushing and sacrifice.
And I think that cycle
describes the average work
life of many, many people.
So what we recommend is a more
holistic plan, a plan that's
going to suggest that you
invest in things that give you
more economic opportunity, but
also give you more opportunity
to be in connection with
people you care about.
Also give you more of
a direct opportunity
to be developing in the
areas that you most care
about developing, that the
substance of your happiness
be included, that you invest
not only in your ability
to take time off, but you
also invest in your ability
to enjoy the work
that you're doing,
and to be valuable in a variety
of uncertain work environments.
MICHAEL ELLSBERG: So what
would an investment plan
look like that took into
account some of the things Bryan
was just saying?
Well, the title of this talk
is "The Last Safe Investment--
Why Investing in Your Human
Capital Outperforms Everything
Else."
So what is human capital?
There's a bunch of
different definitions.
One definition might just
be your net present value
of your lifetime earnings.
That's a technical definition.
A more humanistic definition
might be everything
that you bring to bear to an
hour of labor that adds value
to that hour, other than
the things you're using.
So if you're mopping
a floor, you're
bringing relatively little human
capital to that hour of labor.
If you're doing the
things that you all
are doing as engineers
and so forth, at Google,
you're bringing a lot of human
capital to each hour of labor.
And that human capital
multiplies, essentially,
the value to other
people and the value
you receive financially and
non-financially, in terms
of satisfaction and
enjoyment from your labor.
And our contention
is that as the title
says, that these investments
really outperform the FACD plan
type investments.
And actually, it's not that high
of a bar to beat, especially
over the last 15 years.
As I mentioned, the plan
you see in the books
is that the investments are
supposed to go up about 7%
a year if you're investing
in a low-fee index fund.
Over the last 15 years, if you
had put $10,000 in the S&P 500,
and just watch it grow,
these are very rough numbers.
But it's grown.
It would be worth somewhere
around $16,000 or something
now.
But that's not even
counting inflation.
If you count inflation,
it's hardly grown at all.
It's grown, maybe
like, 1% per year.
So that's 15 years.
That's a third of an
average working life.
So the plan hasn't been working
for a third of the working
lives of the people who
started this plan 15 years ago.
Now, we're not forecasters.
Things might pick up.
The earnings might be so
great in the next 15 years
that it makes up for those
horrible last 15 years.
But we--
BRYAN FRANKLIN:
Except for the people
who wanted to retire today.
MICHAEL ELLSBERG:
Yeah, yeah, except
for the people who are
depending on that last 15 years
starting now.
So the system has
really not been
working for very many
people over the last decade
and a half or so.
Nobody's happy with it.
So what we're saying, is you
have this other great asset
that nobody talks about.
If you earn the median
household income
in America, which is somewhere
around $50,000-- and probably
most of you at Google are
earning more than that.
But let's just talk about
the national median.
And let's say, you
work for 40 years.
Just in that technical
definition of human capital,
you have a net present value
of somewhere around $2 million
of your lifetime earnings.
That's a huge asset for a
22-year-old or 25-year-old
to have access to.
And one of the things that
determines your wealth
is not just the rate of
growth of your investments,
but also the base that
that rate is growing.
And so if you are
trying to save,
the average American
saves only a couple
thousand dollars a year.
Even if you're getting
incredible investment returns--
you're the best
stock picker ever,
you're getting 25%
returns annually--
you're starting from
such a small base
if that's what you're saving,
that it's hard to make action
on that over time.
Whereas, if you consider
your human capital your base,
then you can invest in ways that
even make small improvements
that over time will
have very large impacts
on your financial
returns and also,
just the non-financial
benefits that come
from enjoying your work more,
working at a higher level,
having higher levels
of leadership,
working with bigger and
better teams that excite you
more, harder problems,
that kind of thing.
And we're going to talk more
about specific investments
of your time and money
that you can make.
But let's just say, that
you're earning $150,000 a year.
And let's say, you
decided to invest
$30,000 over a year or two in
a bunch of different skill sets
that would increase your
human capital, your earning.
And not necessarily
just technical skills,
but also things like
leadership skills,
sales and persuasion-- even if
you're not in a sales position,
we're always selling our ideas
to other people-- communication
skills-- all the
humanistic skills
that go along with
technical skills
to make someone really
successful working in a team.
Let's say you invested $15,000,
$20,000, $30,000, over a couple
years.
And let's say, over time,
you got a promotion.
You started working
on bigger problems.
You came up with some great
idea that was implemented.
And then over time
you're earning 20% more.
And so one year of that
pays back your investment.
And then if that keeps
up for a decade or so,
inflation adjusted, you've
just gotten a 10x return
on that investment, roughly.
And those kind of returns
are very, very hard
to achieve on the stock market,
especially without just taking
insane amounts of risk on.
Whereas by our contention,
it's fairly predictable,
the kinds of things
that you can invest in,
in yourself, to
supercharge your already
existing technical
skills to make them more
valuable to a team,
to make them more
likely to lead to promotions
and higher earning
and that sort of thing.
BRYAN FRANKLIN: There's
a cognitive dissonance
where the activity of
investing is normally
thought to be quite passive.
And yet, if you get
into a discussion,
let's say, with an expert
in real estate investing.
And you start to get
into this discussion
like, hey, I've got
half a million dollars.
I want to invest
it in real estate,
and I'd like to
earn 15% or more.
It turns out that the
education that you'll
need to have in order to
make proper use of that money
and not risk losing all of it
is easily several hundred hours,
probably close to 1,000 hours.
And like any skill, in order
to be really masterful at it,
in order to achieve what
some people would call
passive income, you might
have to put 4,000 or 5,000
hours of education time
into learning that,
so that you can start
to have the pattern
recognition that you need
in order to be successful.
Now, if you want to do that,
you can be a successful stock
trader.
You could be a successful
real estate investor.
You can invest in
cryptocurrencies
and be successful at that.
We're not saying that
those aren't vehicles,
where you could apply education
and turn it into money.
I just don't think
it's the easiest one.
There's a lot of
other skills that you
can spend a fraction
of that time learning
that have a much, much
higher chance of return
when applied to
your human capital.
And in the book, we actually
refer to those skills
as the super skills.
They're the most rewarded.
They're highly compensated.
They're universal.
And unlike market
skills-- for example,
a particular technical skill or
learning a particular language,
or learning a
particular technique
or having a particular
ability that you might
put on a resume-- technical
skills and market skills
are driven by how the market
values that particular skill,
which changes over time.
And as we enter periods of
more and more unpredictability
in the job markets and
in the global markets,
then the value of those
skills are also unpredictable.
However, the super skills that
have been value accelerators
ever since human beings were
interacting with each other,
they're the least
likely to change
and the most likely to be
valued over the long term.
And they can multiply
your earning potential
by 5, 10 or even 100 times.
If you look at, for
example, the average CEO
in a company in
the United States
makes 380 times the
average employee
in the firm where
they're leading.
Not everyone here
wishes to be a CEO.
Instead of of, say,
500 hours learning
how to invest in real
estate, if you spent,
say, 100 hours learning the
leadership and other types
of skills that a CEO has-- not
because you want to be one--
the options that you would
have for how much you work,
where you work, on what you
work, which teams you lead,
would be dramatically different.
So when you're looking at an
asset class, an investment
class as an investor, really,
investors want two things.
They want a lot of variability.
They want a lot of variance.
Because if there's no
variance as an investor,
then you can't make money
buying and selling the thing,
if there's no
difference to be had.
And you want a lot
of predictability.
At least, you want to
be able to predict.
So you want it to
go up and down.
And you want to know whether
it's going to go up and down.
And again, compared with the
stock market, the real estate
market and the other
readily-available types
of investments,
your human capital
has much, much,
much more variance.
You know, there's
much more variance
in the value in human capital.
And it's also very,
very predictable.
The kinds of things that
you can do to increase it
will reliably increase it.
MICHAEL ELLSBERG: So what
are these super skills
that we're talking about?
The basic definition that
we have of a super skill
is any skill that
is, essentially,
valuable in almost
any context-- any job,
any industry, any market,
any market conditions.
So these are very
different than, say,
the particular programming
languages that you know,
or technical skills you have.
And they're very basic,
very human types of skills.
You know, how to communicate.
So communication skills,
leadership skills, you know,
there's so many different ways
to invest in being a leader.
There's so many aspects
of being a leader.
A very simple one, for
example, is public speaking.
It's surprising how much
you will set yourself apart
if you learn how to
speak well publicly.
And it's surprising
how easy it is
and inexpensive it is to learn.
In fact, I would
say, if I had to say,
the single most
highly-leveraged investment
you could make probably would
be public speaking skills.
And you can go to Toastmasters
for however many dollars
per month.
And whatever it is,
there's plenty of avenues.
This is the kind of
thing that can really
supercharge your already
existing technical skills.
It's a bottleneck, in a way.
Take two people who have PhDs
and have invested decades
of their lives in their
education, countless hours,
countless hundreds of thousands
of dollars, or student debt,
or whatever it is.
One of them is a
horrible public speaker.
One of them has
spent a year training
to be a public speaker.
I know which one I
would put my money on,
in terms of where they're
going to go in their career.
So the super skills are
sort of like bottlenecks.
They get rid of bottlenecks.
Where are areas where all
the traditional human capital
you've invested in-- your
education, your training,
your technical skills--
where the value of that
is not being fully
realized because there's
some human kind of
person-to-person skill
set that you haven't
fully brushed up on yet,
and you could take
to the next level?
Another one that
I've mentioned a lot
is sales, marketing,
and persuasion.
Now, you may hear
those words and think,
oh I'm not a sales person.
I'm not in the marketing team.
It doesn't matter to me.
Wrong.
Anytime you're on a team,
you're in sales and marketing.
You have ideas.
You need to get
budget for your ideas.
You need approval.
You need your higher ups
to sign up on things.
These are all sales, persuasion,
and marketing problems.
BRYAN FRANKLIN:
Attracting talent.
I mean, there's--
MICHAEL ELLSBERG: Yeah.
And they can be learned.
They can be learned,
also, in ways
that don't violate your
basic values of being
a decent human being.
A lot of people hear those
words and they think,
oh well, sales-- they think of a
used car salesman or something.
And that's really bad sales.
And good sales is
a discipline that
actually takes into account
what the person being persuaded
wants and has them feel really
happy about what they're
getting, and how
that ties to what
you're trying to accomplish.
It's a very
human-centric discipline.
And another one we're
going to be talking
about quite a bit for
the rest of this talk
is building what might be
called social capital-- it's
a part of your human capital--
which is who you know,
and who your community
is, and specifically,
who your tribe is.
And we're going be talking a
lot about this concept of tribe.
Because it's-- we think-- the
most important aspect of human
capital, and the
least discussed.
BRYAN FRANKLIN: My
conjecture would
be many of you would prefer
if we lived in a meritocracy.
And most of the people
who are highly technically
capable that I've
worked with often
behave as though they live
in a meritocracy, where
the merit of your work
stands on its own.
And there's something that
feels very good about that.
And when you can have a
relationship with someone
where you can see each
other's work for what
it is and acknowledge
it for what it is,
that can be quite special.
However, it's not the
observable world that I see.
What I see is that between
the results you create
and the perception
of those results,
it's actually the
perception of those results
that will yield the
most acknowledgment
from other people.
And those other people,
often, are decision makers
as to what kind of resources
you have access to.
Now, also I would say, if
it was a room only full
of sales people, I would
say, the results actually
matter as well, and particularly
for your own relationship
to how you feel about your work.
If you are only
managing perception
but you know the
results aren't there,
that leads to a very, very
dissatisfying experience
personally.
And since we're talking about
how to create an investment
plan that actually you
end up being happy,
you really need both.
So for the rest of
the time, I think
we wanted to focus on one
of the particular-- what
we call-- true wealth assets.
That really amplifies both your
financial wealth-- literally,
the amount of
money in the bank--
and also amplifies the other
aspects of your human capital,
and the other aspects
of what we would
call your financial
ecosystem, which
includes all of the things
that your finances are meant
to give you-- your sense
of happiness and freedom
and development.
And Michael mentioned
already that we
want to talk about tribe.
So tribe is a fascinating asset.
Because it's absolutely
coveted the least by those
that don't have it.
And it's treasured the
most by those that do.
It's cited by those that do have
a strong tribe as the number
one source of economic and
non-economic opportunity.
So we're going to
define tribe for you.
Because it's a
subset of community.
Not all communities, in
our view, are tribes.
So here's what a tribe is.
It is a networked
values-based group of friends.
So it's friendships where each
person is deeply connected
to each other person.
If you have 100
friends, but mostly they
don't know each other,
that's not a tribe.
That kind of hub-and-spoke
model is not a tribe.
And it's not a tribe
because the value of tribe
comes from the
network effect, which
you're quite familiar with.
And the kind of values
that you can get,
the kind of benefits you can
get through relationships--
whether it's like, you are
recommended for a position
that you want to have, or there
is a project that you hear
about that you want
to be involved in,
or that your unique skills
are known and recognized,
those kinds of values that
you get from a relationship--
and you probably
know 80% of all jobs
are gotten through
personal referrals,
not through the HR
department with the resume.
So that value that you
get through individual
relationships is
multiplied in a network
the same way the
value of any node
is multiplied in a
technical network,
through the network effect.
So for it to be a
tribe, everybody
must know everybody else.
It also-- for it to be a
tribe-- must be based on values
that the tribe has in common,
that each person in the tribe
is dedicated to living and to
accentuating in each other.
So you know, if you live in
a homeowner's association--
if you have a condo or
you live where you live
has an HOA-- that's a community
that's based on where you live,
not based on values.
So it's very unlikely
for that to be a tribe.
In fact, why most
homeowners associations
are such a nightmare-- if you've
ever been on the board of one
and that kind of thing--
endless petty fighting
is the typical scene in an HOA.
And the reason for
that is because you've
got a bunch of people
who have shared interests
where the decisions
impact each other.
But they don't
have shared values.
And that's what
makes it so painful.
So it's networked and
it's values based.
And not just any values, but
the values of contribution--
meaning where you want to
contribute as much value as
possible during your life,
versus just extract as much
as you can-- the value of
development or growth--
where you want yourself to be
the best version of yourself
that you can, and
you want your friends
to be the best versions
of them, that they
can be, as well-- and then the
value of being in service--
where you want your collective
effort to matter, to make
someone else's life better.
Those three values have to
be included in the values
that the tribe holds
in order for it
to be the kind of
tribe that's going
to yield truly economic benefit
for you as well non-economic.
So that's what a tribe is.
I'd say the smallest tribe would
be probably 15 to 20 people.
And according to Dunbar's
research, he would say,
the largest would be 150.
Because at about-- he says--
150 is the average number
of simultaneous
connections you can
hold in your mind at one time
before you start losing track.
Imagine that you have
the seed of a tribe,
if you've got some friendships.
And maybe you already
have a tribe already.
And maybe you don't.
Most people don't.
So let's say, you don't.
MICHAEL ELLSBERG: Could
you just maybe explain
just a little bit what that
might look like, for somebody
in this room, to have a tribe?
BRYAN FRANKLIN: Sure.
So having a tribe
would be-- imagine
there are 35 friends who all
are dedicated to similar values.
And you find ways of connecting
and getting together regularly.
Maybe it's every month
or every three weeks.
And you're constantly
aware of and tracking
each other's progress
in your lives,
in terms of what's important
to you and how much of that
stuff are you having.
It may all be Googlers.
It may be a mix of people
here and other companies.
But what do you
do have in common
is this sense of wanting
to develop into the best
version of yourself you can
be, and wanting to contribute.
And then so the kinds
of conversations
you're likely to have are
like, hey, what's going on?
How are you doing?
Like, tell me about
this contribution.
Or tell me about this
thing that you're learning.
And you're constantly sharing
those kinds of experiences
together as friends.
So we found that tribe has
an absolutely massive impact
on a person's felt
sense of wealth
and also, indeed, their
actual financial wealth.
And when you add
the asset of tribe--
we've tested it over
10 years-- the gains
that you can get-- both
financial and non-financial--
are just staggering.
One of them is something we call
the Happiness Exchange Rate.
So given that we all want
to make money in order
to exchange that money for
some form of happiness, be it
freedom or enjoyment
or luxury or prestige
or some kind of
experience like that.
Your personal wealth
is actually governed,
to a great degree,
by how efficient
you are, personally, at
making that exchange.
How efficient are you
at exchanging money
for those experiences?
So if you spend a lot of money
and don't get the experience
you were hoping
to have from it--
for example, if you
buy a $100,000 car,
but then sitting in the
car you don't feel special
or whatever it is, or
attractive or powerful,
or you don't have any of
the feelings you were hoping
that the car would give
you, then, in a way,
you wasted that $100,000.
Someone who is able to derive
the experiences they want
from the purchases they make is
going to have a lot more money
and a lot more felt
sense of wealth
than someone who
continually needs
to spend more and more
money, but the experience
they were hoping to
have eludes them.
And it turns out that one of
the ways that these experiences
that we want are conveyed
are through these kinds
of networked friendships.
Where if you want to
feel a certain way
or be thought of
in a certain way,
and that's part of
your development
that your group of
friends is aware of and is
committed to, then actually,
when you start spending time
with them, indeed you
start to feel that way
and become that thing.
So it's tremendously
positive from the point
of view of your
Happiness Exchange Rate,
where you have to spend less
and less dollars in order to get
the same degree of fulfillment.
And then there's
more and more left
in the savings account for
you to add to your wealth.
And of course, tribes
share resources.
You know, it's funny.
An economist would
say, that an invitation
to sail around the world
on your friend's yacht
doesn't increase
your balance sheet.
But if you own a yacht
and it's in dry dock
and you're paying
the maintenance fees,
then that is an asset.
We would say, that the
former is an asset.
And the latter is just
a liability, really.
So when you have a tribe,
if you have 150 people who
share resources and share
values and share experiences,
one of our friends has a
50-foot yacht in Grenada.
Another one of our friends
has a place in Vail.
has a place in Ibiza.
So there are
constantly events that
utilize these types of assets.
But we don't all need
all of the assets.
We start to specialize
in the kinds of ones
that we want to maintain.
And since the way
to utilize an asset
like that is to share it
with friends, then all of us
are the richer because of it.
MICHAEL ELLSBERG:
Another benefit
that comes from tribe that
really, in my opinion,
is where the financial power of
this comes, is the networking
and informational
aspects of finding
about new opportunities-- let's
just say, within a company,
finding out where
the hot projects are,
where the inside scoop on
what's happening where,
and what is exciting for
you to be involved with,
that kind of thing,
who's looking for what
kind of talent, if
and when someone
is ready to have a
different career.
Or let's say, there's
an economic downturn
and people are getting laid off.
It's also a hedge against
risk, in that two people get
laid off.
One of them just has
a loose connection
of friends that they go
drinking with after work.
And another person is part
of a really vibrant tribe,
as we're talking about,
with a diversity of people
who are in different areas and
working at different companies.
Again, the second one is
the person I would bet
is going to weather that
economic storm a lot more.
In my opinion, the
only search engine
that could possibly
deliver better
and more tailored
and more relevant
search results than
Google, is your tribe.
It couldn't give you the results
on such a wide range of topics.
But it can give you,
for very specific,
highly, highly relevant
pieces of information
such as, where is
there someone who
might be looking to hire someone
with me, with my skill set?
Or where is there x,y, or z
type of social opportunity that
I'm looking for,
dating opportunity,
anything like that.
Your tribe delivers to you
the most relevant, valuable,
directed search
results possible.
And it's a huge benefit,
both financially
for economic opportunity, and
also for social opportunity.
Who do you want to know?
What kinds of events?
These are the kind of things
that massively increase
your felt sense of wealth.
Because again, yes, money
in the bank is important.
And we're, in no way,
here to deny that.
But as important, if
not more important,
is how you feel with the
opportunities and the things
you're able to do
with that money.
And your tribe
really is the filter
through which the money
in your bank account
is going to be filtered into
the experiences you have
and whether those are
really, really rich
and rewarding experiences
that feel incredibly
meaningful to you over
time, or whether they're
toss-away experiences
that you forget.
BRYAN FRANKLIN: Tribe also has,
to me, a fascinating impact
on reputation.
If you think of reputation
as like, stored goodwill.
Or it could be stored ill will.
But let's just talk about
positive reputation for now.
So if your positive reputation
is your stored goodwill
with others, which then causes
them to reinterpret what you
say, what you do more
positively as a result.
If someone has a very
positive reputation,
it only takes a small bit
of positivity from them.
And then you sort of imbue all
of the rest of the positivity.
Someone with a really
positive reputation
can get far, far more access.
And reputation is stored as
goodwill in relationships.
But again, if you had a
hub-and-spoke kind of set
up, where the relationships
between the different people
that you were
closest to was weak,
then goodwill that you'd
restore in one relationship
wouldn't transfer to another.
Because they don't have
goodwill with each other.
So in a tribe, every time you
contribute or help someone
along their self
development journey,
or give them access to
a resource they needed,
or offer them a
job, or offer them
a connection, or an investor,
or a co-founder, whatever
it is, each time
you do that, you
get a positive
stored reputation,
a positive stored
goodwill, in all
of the members of the tribe.
And it has this kind
of compounding effect
so that your reputation
with that group of people
can get actually
quite astronomical.
And so we took one of the true
wealth assets, the tribe--
of which there are three.
And we talked a little bit
about your super skills,
one of the true
well disciplines--
of which there are three.
Just to show you how
these things can actually
have a both an economic
and a non-economic benefit.
And we've have about
18 minutes left,
if you want to go
to some questions.
AUDIENCE: So I actually
do have a tribe.
And it's a tribe of moms.
And I can tell you, that
when one person's husband got
in a serious car accident, they
didn't cook dinner for a month.
And we only have one carpet
cleaner that makes the rounds.
But that's very
different, in some ways,
from the economic impact
to the kind of tripe
you're talking about.
You know, ,a group of moms
is amazing when you need some
emergency child care.
But it's not going to do
the same sort of thing
in terms of
employment networking
or financial networking.
How does your advice
change for people
who, maybe their
natural affinity
group isn't white males
in high-powered jobs?
Like, how does this
work if you're black
and in the inner city?
Is this actually just amplifying
existing inequalities?
BRYAN FRANKLIN: That's
a great question.
So one of the things that's
essential to a tribe--
and Michael mentioned
it very, very briefly.
And I think I kind of skipped
over it-- is diversity.
Diversity's absolutely
essential to a tribe.
It's good to have some
powerful white men in there.
But it's much better to have
artists and moms and people
in various different economic
and social conditions,
but that each share
the same values.
Because then the perspectives
that are brought to the tribe
are that much richer.
What we've noticed--
we come from California
and from Silicon
Valley-- and there
are communities of people who
are the powerful Silicon Valley
elite.
But they're quite stale.
And they would not qualify,
from my perspective, as a tribe.
There is certainly
economic opportunity
to be derived from those
kinds of communities,
of powerful people.
But the non-economic
opportunity is quite limited.
And our experience
when someone like that
is introduced to our tribe
or introduced to friends that
have a much broader range
of backgrounds is it's
incredibly enlivening for
them and enriching for them.
Because it's, again, different
perspectives on the same value.
But diversity is essential.
That's what I would say.
MICHAEL ELLSBERG:
I would just add
real quickly, if you think
of the word richness,
it's a word I like a lot.
Because it may seem
like rich means
having lots of one thing,
like having lots of money
or having lots of
gold, or whatever.
But actually, if
you use the word
rich as in the
richness of the novel's
language or a rich flavor, or
a rich musical composition,
what it actually means is lots
of different things interacting
in very subtle and
interesting ways.
And so yes, a tribe of
just rich white dudes
might have a lot of financial
wealth running through it.
And maybe that's what
those people want.
But that's just
the financial side.
Like Bryan said, I've hung
out with those kind of people.
Anyone who's been to a party
of just one type of person
in one economic class and
one race, or whatever,
it doesn't have
that alive richness.
To actually realize the
experiential side of wealth,
you want a richness that is not
in the richness sense of lots
of money, but a richness like
lots of different things,
lots of different
kinds of people,
different backgrounds,
different outlooks,
interacting in ways, again,
with some shared value system.
We don't want to cacophony
But interacting
in different ways
so that we're all
learning from each other.
And that is much
more likely to lead
to a richness of experience.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
And I was going
to say, maybe I'm
more antisocial than I thought.
But when you guys started
talking about the tribes,
I'm not sure I know
anyone in my own network
who belongs to a tribe.
I'm not even sure I know
anyone who knows of a tribe.
The numbers that you cited,
a minimum of 15, 20 people,
and then up to 150,
those seemed higher to me
than what I expected.
So would you mind
sharing a few thoughts
about your tribes,
where you're in,
and how do tribes come about?
How do they form and live?
And I mean, obviously
I'm not talking
about like, forced tribes
where it's circumstance
like, I don't know,
religion or ethnicity
or living in the
same condo house.
But yeah, how do they
work, organically?
MICHAEL ELLSBERG: Yeah.
Thank you.
That's a great question.
People ask us,
well, have you have
you used this
financial plan you're
talking about for 40 years?
And the answer is no.
I'm not even 40 years old yet.
And so what is the basis?
Why are we up here, feeling
like we have any credibility
to talk about these things?
Well, we have been using
this plan for about 15 years.
And specifically,
the part where we
feel we've realized the most
value and have something very,
very tangible that is a
thing that we can point to,
that's really adding
value to our lives,
is the cultivation of a tribe--
specifically in the Bay Area.
Mostly, also, we're
connected to New York.
One thing that's really
important to note
is it's not centered
around one person.
So this isn't a cult. This isn't
a religious movement with one
leader or something like that.
It's a natural affinity of
people that have really just
had this intention.
We were sort of,
like, going around,
looking for other people
who had this intention
to live-- not on a commune.
We actually don't
live communally.
There's a few group
homes-- in a community.
Or more than community-- what
we're talking about-- tribe.
So it looks like
there's a consistency.
It's the first time
I've really felt,
in my life, this sort of
consistency of people who
care about me, who intend for
me to do better in my life,
and I intend for them.
And it was cultivated
relatively intentionally.
And maybe you can talk about
how it gets cultivated?
BRYAN FRANKLIN: Yeah.
I also want to just
note that there
are those in the tribe who
earn less than $30,000 a year.
And there are those in the tribe
who have a net worth in excess
of $100 million.
So it's quite a range.
And the how is it
begins, really,
with a soul search for you,
of what you care most about.
Imagine looking
back on your life,
and asking yourself
in what way did
you want to change
other people's
experiences for the better.
And if you look
at the work you do
and the way you
like to socialize,
and kind of relationships
you like to have,
the times when
you have felt most
fulfilled probably correlate
to other people being
benefited in a specific way.
And so I would
begin by identifying
what that is, and then start to
talk with my existing friends
about that specific benefit.
Like, hey, I notice
that I really
care about people feeling this
way or having this experience,
or being benefited
in a specific way.
And naturally, because they're
your friends, some of them
will share this value.
And then I would start just
getting together with them
and having dinner parties
and having the question--
what do you suppose we
could do together somewhere
in the two-hour-a-week
kind of time commitment,
or one hour a week, what do you
think that we could do together
that would maximize that impact?
Or maximize our
individual ability
to have that impact
in our lives?
And just start having the
question be in the friendships
that you have.
And that is the
nucleus of a tribe.
Once you start asking that
and answering that together
and discovering it
together, then you
start to gain understandings
and technologies
for how you can collaborate
inside of a work environment,
outside a work environment,
to have that impact.
AUDIENCE: So the short answer
is make your own tribe?
BRYAN FRANKLIN: Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, I
would start that.
And then what will
happen as you do that,
is you'll start to notice
other existing tribes that are
currently not on your radar.
And then you might glob onto
one or be adopted by one
or join one.
That has happened
as well, with us.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's interesting
that what seems like
almost just life advice,
you're putting it in a form
of investment advice, which
is a neat twist.
But taking that
as an approach, I
think about a lot
of your advice seems
like it's further investment
in your one big investment,
which is yourself.
A lot of times, people think
about traditional financial
investing as a way
of diversifying over
their complete investment in
their own skills and abilities
so that they don't--
maybe someday,
if they lose some of those
skills and abilities,
they'll still be able
to eat and have shelter.
So what do you think about
the diversification question?
BRYAN FRANKLIN: Yeah,
so first of all,
I don't think we can
diversify, other than ourself.
I think we have
the one unit here.
And the way that the principle
of diversification to me
applies to this life
advice, is to invest
in the kinds of relationships
and the kinds of skills
that are valuable in the
most diverse situations.
In terms of there's
this idea of retirement,
or when I want to
stop adding value
but want to still
be getting value.
And the way that we address
that in the book, in the plan,
is to look at the idea of
advisor equity, or how can
you start to have the
kinds of contributions
that you make be divorced from
the time you spend making them?
Which is a rather
advanced concept.
But if you're invested in say,
a tribe of 150 people, which
are diverse people,
and you're continually
building positive capital
with them, then more and more,
their success can be a part of
your future financial success.
And we can all share,
basically, our future benefit.
The more the tribe starts
to span generations,
the more the elder
generation is taken care
of by the generation that
is in their working prime.
MICHAEL ELLSBERG: One thing
I would add to that, also,
on this question
of diversification,
is our belief is that you
should not be risking money just
to get more money.
So basically, everyone
needs savings.
We need savings, perhaps
a lot of savings,
to weather different
storms, or to retire, to not
have to work for some period.
But in our opinion, that
should really be savings.
Like, a lot of people
think when they put money
in a 401K, that's savings.
No, it's not.
That's investing.
That's risking.
I mean, people saw just
how much that was risking.
Same thing with the home.
Home equity is not savings.
It's an investment that is
taking a lot of risk, actually.
And we saw the risk,
again, about 10 years ago.
In my opinion, the ways
we should risk our money
involve doing things
where it's a project where
money isn't the only thing
we're going to get back.
And there's some value actually
occurring in the risk itself,
that there's some experiential
value in the risk.
Take, say, an example
from my own life.
I'm a writer.
I just spent-- invested--
six months of my time
and quite a bit of money getting
a manuscript ready for an agent
and possible publication.
It didn't end up working out.
I won't go into all the details.
But basically, nothing
came of that six months.
Now, had that been purely me
spending that time or the time
value of the money and
putting it in a stock
and then the stock went to zero,
I'd be pretty pissed about it
and pretty bummed.
But actually, I was
able to learn things
from this experience.
I was able to get ideas.
I was able to come away from
it feeling like, OK, well, it
didn't turn out
the way I wanted.
But I actually
learned something.
And now I'm going to
go in this direction.
So that has this sort of
experiential quality, where
the money being
invested was tied up
in things that had a
tie to my life narrative
in such a way that the
risk almost wasn't a risk.
It was just part
of doing the things
that I wanted to do in
life and learning, which
is what we all do.
So yeah, diversification of some
things that are really, really,
really low risk.
And then the things
that are higher
risk are tied up in
the things you actually
care about and the
kind of narrative
that you're building
of your life story.
BRYAN FRANKLIN: I also
want to point out that it's
an important economic theory.
It's an important
investment theory.
But it actually hasn't worked
out for the average person.
98% of baby boomers
say, they don't
have enough money to retire.
So it hasn't worked,
is the problem.
You know?
If the existing
advice was working,
then I think we
probably wouldn't
have written that book.
And the theory of
diversification, again,
for it to take hold, requires
a massive education investment
in investing in that
particular asset class,
to learn what is actually
diversified and what isn't.
So it just reminded
me of that part.
AUDIENCE: I was
just wondering how
you reconcile-- my mom was a
public school teacher growing
up.
So it was all about
not being in a clique.
And kids would be
like, be in my crew.
I like you.
And I have been following her
advice through high school,
college, business school, etc.
And so when I get approached,
be in my lean-in circle,
or be in my crew, or we're
a clique, we're the girls,
we're the Plastics, whatever
it may be, great pitch, right?
I've been declining on purpose
and following my parents'
advice not to be part
of a said tribe, where
there are a distinct number
of people in a group.
So how do reconcile that
advice and your own,
to try to create a tribe?
BRYAN FRANKLIN: Sure.
So the first is that the cliques
that you were told not to join
had, as a primary value,
exclusion of others.
That was, like, their number
one deal, was to exclude others.
And for any tribe
to be healthy, it
has to have porous boundaries.
People have to be able to join
and leave as it suits them,
without much drama.
And the way that you
would join our tribe
is if you had the same values
and you started to hang out.
Or you knew someone, you
got invited to an event,
and then you were
at the event, you
wanted to come to another one.
And you were there.
If you were there
more often, you're
going to be in, provided
that you are actually
living in accordance to
the values of service
and contribution, of freedom,
of devotion, and of growth.
So I think the difference
between a healthy tribe
and an unhealthy
clique, or even a cult,
is the values that
it's centered around.
And they have to really
resonate as your values.
So that's the first
thing I'd say.
MICHAEL ELLSBERG: What
does Jennifer call it?
Like, a duocracy or something?
BRYAN FRANKLIN:
Oh, effortocracy.
MICHAEL ELLSBERG:
Yeah, effortocracy.
Like, the cliques
you're talking about,
it's about prestige and who's
cool, and who's not cool.
And better metric,
we think, is a tribe
that basically people
who are doing the most
to create the events or make
things happen for people,
or support each other,
they're the ones who
are kind of rising
naturally to leadership.
So it's almost like an
effortocracy, rather than
a cool-ocracy.
Thank you for having us.
Thank you for taking an
hour out of your day.
[APPLAUSE]